[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
de conjugar en subjuntivo
si al menos subjuntivo quisiera conjugar
conmigo
tan altos sueños son los que me esperan
que conjugar me desespera jugando ya
pase la vida entera
no no no no no
no no no
toronto loro toro está brotan de mis
ojos ojalá se resbalan por los huecos en
que ya no estás gritan desmemoria por
caminos clausurados pero amo el camino
aunque me haya equivocado porque soy así
soy las cosas que yo vi y las que nunca
fui hablo en pretérito perfecto por más
errores que haya cometido sigo vivo y el
tiempo me dirá lo que es correcto
brutón
raro
[Música]
no
d
ojalá el presente se construya
al margen de ojalá
que sea un árbol a ras del suelo y con
su pelo abrace todo el cielo
ojalá que abarque tu mirada tantas
miradas como paso vas a dar que el
tiempo avanza inesperado lo que miraba
es conjuga y han pasado ya te inspires y
yo hubiera dicho que vuelvan nosotros
riamos ustedes perdonen pero ellos
dejarán de ser otra edad
todos
al margen de un
[Música]
qué miedo me da
la vez
hay libertad en la verdad que tu fe en
el miedo
[Música]
más fácil es bajar la nube hasta los
pies
[Música]
que crecer hasta el cielo besar la nube
hacer yo
[Música]
samborombón
sambora bombón
[Música]
samborondón
samborombón
cargado de ti
me voy al cielo a sembrar las
pretexto de vivir
ran fueron las tormentas las nubes más
negras los días que pasan las noches que
abrazan respirar respirar que no hay
despedidas
ojalá
al presente se construía
al margen de ojalá
que sea un árbol a ras del suelo y con
su pelo abrace todo el cielo ojala que
abarque tu mirada
tantas miradas como paso vas a dar que
el tiempo avanza inesperado lo que
miraba conjugarían pasado yo haga te
inspires y ya hubiera dicho que vuelva
nosotros riamos ustedes perdonen pero
ellos dejarán de ser otra edad
claro te inspires e idea hubiera dicho
que vuelvas nosotros riamos ustedes
perdonen pero ellos dejarán de ser otra
edad
[Música]
al margen dios
[Aplausos]